today I am honored to have my good
friend
Aileen Lee here and we're going to have
a conversation about stuff yeah well I
hope we talk about like alien is is is a
very public personality in the in the
venture world so there's lots of great
talk she has given online and I hope not
to do too much of that with she she
tells a lot of amazing things so it'll
be hard to avoid but so this would just
be the the latest version of pearls of
wisdom from alien but hopefully we'll
try to push the conversation in other
areas if we can so how about a welcome
for Aileen Lee welcome to startup school
thank you I'm happy to be here
so you they might not know that much
about your kind of interesting and I was
the idiosyncratic career that led you to
being the founder of of cowboy ventures
maybe we can just start with you giving
a quick overview of your background I
don't know from the gap to to now we're
definitely going to do a QA and like
your time schedule is actually they can
stay because because the one of the
reasons we're doing this at YC now
instead of at Stanford is that Stanford
you're like constrained or not this is
our building so usually we talk for 30
or 40 minutes and then do a QA
whatever's natural so do you have a hard
stop at all I can't remember but okay
probably okay okay okay hi everyone
thanks so much for spending time here
I'm really appreciative I'm a lean it's
like I am a first-generation immigrant
my parents are both from China so I'm a
very like I grew up in a very
traditional like our family had nothing
we they saved up money to buy Chinese
restaurant people in the family worked
in the Chinese restaurant like and I
grew up in New Jersey so you grew up
with entrepreneurs kind of yeah I mean I
guess I guess I mean I think
immigrants are entrepreneurs right
because you come here with nothing and
you have to figure out how to get a job
and how to find a place to live and how
to make it work and yeah like I think
there's a phrase a kleiner we used to
say like an entre definition of an
entrepreneur is like who does more than
anyone thought possible with less than
anyone thought possible and I think
that's probably true for entrepreneurs
for immigrants as well I bet that
resonates with a lot of people in the
audio and but I was fortunate that like
my parents were very focused on
education so I wanted going to MIT being
in completely over my head and then I
did a mess of banking for a couple years
I guess the idiosyncrasy I lived in
China for a year and taught English and
studied Chinese I went to business
school and at business school I was
always really interested in brands and
in particular consumer brands and how
they generate a lot of working at
customer love and so I cut it and this
is like kind of pre-internet so I used
to go to the library and read Fast
Company and ink magazine to try and find
names of companies that were kind of
up-and-coming and I would then look them
up in the phone book and just so quick
now I went to the library how many
people have gone to the library like
read magazines yeah like five that's how
we did it back then or you could look up
and you could look up older magazines on
something called microfiche raise your
hand if you know what microfiche is oh
cool
and so I found a company called Odwalla
and a company called The North Face and
they're both out here and so I called
like I would just call the phone number
and just ask to talk to whoever would
talk to me and I convinced them to hire
me for the summer so I did like two
months that wanted to month and they're
both kind of private I guess that now
they would because their growth
companies and I did marketing and then
after business school I went to gap and
you know my family was not that into me
going to work for Gap you know he was
and all this time trying to get a good
education
maybe retail is not the place to go but
I feel really passionate about like I
was gonna have the opportunity work with
really smart people in Gap at the time
was such like a talent magnet in retail
like some I think the smartest planners
and merchants and visual designers and
we're working at the company and we were
just kind of on fire and so I spent
three years working different operating
rules like I worked on the supply chain
projects trying to figure out where
stuff was it's called glass pipeline and
then I got a job I worked as chief of
staff to the CEO for a year kind of just
doing everything from helping prepare
for public company board meetings to
making sure they'd hit a good parking
space when we went to go on store visits
and and then my last job there was the
online store in 1999 and our online
store was just we were Capcom was the
only thing we had we weren't sure if we
were going to Old Navy or Banana
Republic calm because we weren't sure if
this dot-com thing was going to stick
and turned out yeah yeah exactly I think
you and I have been working for you know
20-something years since then we should
have just bought Amazon stock just like
chilled yeah you mean you didn't I did
suggest at one point that that well I
was at Yahoo that we buy Amazon I went
and what happened they think that was a
smart idea they no they said they said
the you know would screw up our multiple
yeah yes I worked with Friendster right
yeah and there was this little startup
called Facebook yeah and I remember
talking to them about maybe I think they
wanted 20 million and we wanted to make
15 stories so anyways I was helping run
the dot-com part of gap in 1999 and it
was exciting but also just not a pure
play tech company and so much was
happening in the.com boom so I just said
you know I think I should go work at a
tech company and so I sent my resume
whoever would read it and I wound up
getting an interview at this from
kleiner perkins and they I think they
thought it would be novel to hire a
woman your gender is what and and also
that I had been chief of staff to the
CEO I think was kind of like a good con
training for to be an associated venture
firm so I went up working for a partner
there named John doar for four or five
years and we just super hit it off and
John is a legend in venture capital and
we were working with like Google and
Amazon and just we had incredible
relationships and
and got to meet incredible people and I
was also like the the dumping ground of
every business plan that was sent to
kleiner perkins at the time and so every
night I would just take home duffel bags
of printed business plans and read them
and it was an amazing experience and I
it was like a two to three year job
there oftentimes at venture firms it's
very opaque in terms of is like there is
not really a career path and that was
not a career path job but I wound up
staying for 13 years but you stayed for
13 years but there was a gap in the
middle where you became a CEO I always
felt like I didn't have enough operating
experience especially not I hadn't been
a venture backed CEO and I think you
know a lot of this may be old school
thinking but that kleiner the thought
was like you know it's really hard to
give advice to a start-up CEO if you
haven't done it yourself and if you know
haven't run the functions you haven't
lived through the experience you haven't
really put yourself on the line and so
an opportunity came up where a company
that we had invested in and I was on the
board of was had two co-founders and not
neither of them was clearly the CEO and
they asked me to come in and help and I
was really excited to have the
opportunity to work with them and to get
some more operating spirit so I spent I
took kind of two years off from kleiner
and I went and ran this company it was a
digital media company it was like kind
of an ad sales driven business in the
digital life out of home space at the
time there's a company in China called
focus media that had like an eight or
nine billion dollar market cap taking
kind of what had been paper billboards
and turning them into digital and
running basically like kind of a content
management system and kind of like an ad
network for for digital billboards and
that's what we were trying to build at
RMG's I want to be CEO at the time kind
of it was it was a great experience and
we we thought we had our model locked
and loaded in O seven so we raised a
twenty million dollar series B which at
the time in O seven was a big B and
notes like a day yeah exactly now it's
like a seed joke but I have seen seeds
that large right and then you know eight
happened and we went of having to lay
off half the company but then we also
like because we had this nice with a lot
we can we kind of anticipated winter was
coming and we kept our powder dry so we
were able to live through it we went
acquiring two of our closest competitors
and then I replaced myself with like a
better CEO and I went back to kleiner so
it was a I was I felt really fortunate
Akito is hard though really
so do you feel that you were right and
that that experience did help you give
better advice to CEOs and and what so it
might be hard looking back now but what
what did you learn as CEO that informs
the advice you give now I mean I had
never I guess many things one is I'm
kind of a people person I love talking
to people and I saw I thought that would
naturally translate into being a great
manager and I had managed some people at
Gap but not a ton but I think it's very
different being a CEO or a leader where
people you have to first convince them
to work there you know work at your
company and I turned out to be not as
good at this as I thought but we have
different reports like you have a head
of engineering a head of marketing a
head of sales a head of financing they
often have different personalities and
you want them to have different
personalities and they have different
strengths but that means they often if
they managed in different ways like you
have to communicate with them in
different ways and kind of like figure
out what is the style of communication
and rhythm and like what's the what are
the words that are going to help them do
their best
you have to modulate it by person at
least that's what I found and I that had
not been intuitive to me I thought you
could just be yourself and everything I
don't know if you know I I had a mentor
of mine who used to call that touch and
I think one of the things that's
interesting as a start-up founder like
most of the folks in start-up school are
struggling to find product market fit
yeah and they're thinking about that and
I thinking about that and at some point
they sometimes they lose track of the
fact that really especially if for
example they talked to an investor like
you you're evaluating that but you're
also looking at this person and
wondering could you hire a VP of
Marketing a VP of Sales a VP of
engineering can you can you attract the
right people can do you have do you have
what it takes to be a leader as a
founder and I think people sometimes as
you're struggling just to get a customer
you lose track of actually what it takes
to really grow up that's absolutely
right which is and I'm sure we'll talk
about that which is like what are
investors thinking like we're thinking
about short term and long term when we
talk to you like we're thinking about
whether you can accomplish the short
term but also what comes after that and
what comes after that and whether you
are demonstrating that you can parallel
path in a way they
thinking about how the short-term is a
setup for the long-term effect the
reality is the only thing that matters
to investors is the future the present
is only an indication of what the future
may just look like because they're
betting on your future yep exactly
the other thing I'd say I guess many
things about being a startup CEO like I
had never hired salespeople before I
didn't know how to create a compensation
structure for salespeople or you know
I'm like how do you create on it like
sometimes when you do that your comp you
create unintended consequences by how
you compensate people I found like I
hired these you know different kinds of
sometimes experienced people sometimes
inexperienced people like you know what
kind of how do you want to place bets on
people who are unproven versus pay up
for people who are somewhat proven but
sometimes they come out of platforms
where the platform was doing really well
it's not really clear that the person
was really good so I learned a lot of
lessons around that and also just in
sales in general and I'm sure many of
you who are trying to get product market
fit experiences like sialic lead
qualification is really important like
you yourself and your sales team can
deceive yourself into thinking that
making progress by having a lot of
meetings but the reality is a lot of
those leads are never gonna close and so
figuring out like what how should you
spend your time and how do you qualify
leads so that you're really spending
time on the accounts that are a good fit
for you and are actually good closeable
in the time and the money that you have
is something that I have learned the
hard way
well that's a good luck I was thinking
about that yesterday because I was
talking to a founder who whose company
was betting on a deal closing and and
that deal just didn't close and we were
talking about it and the problem was
that they didn't really have that bad a
problem like the problem he was solving
it was a problem and they were there was
a few people who kind of interested in
solving it but it wasn't a real heart
problem and those are the wrong
customers to spend a lot of time with
and if you don't figure that out early
yeah and even if you close them if it's
not sustainable
yeah like then you just live kind of
campaign a campaign or
quarter-to-quarter and you can't like
that your turn is gonna be high you're
not gonna build up sell the people so
you kind of like like you were saying
about short term plus long term like
it's it's hard enough just to close them
but you have to be able to like close
that same person maybe with more money
every quarter and if you think you're
gonna be able to close them but they're
not going to come back sometimes it's
not even worth closing them he's like
all that stuff that I had never done
before
that I learned well Tyler Bosnia Bosman
II from from clever is coming to talk
about sales next week so that's the yeah
perfect setup that so I think we should
talk a lot about a lot more about what
investors are are looking for but but
I've been thinking you've talked a lot
about that before and and said a lot of
amazing things but I was thinking a
little bit about from startup founders
perspective how how they should look at
investors and what they should look at I
was thinking about you and one of the
things I thought was somewhat different
about you was the level of empathy you
bring to the the founders who come to
you and that investors you know but I
think it's different I think that it
that there's a there's a level of help
you give which is not just you know
here's how you should think about sales
but here's how you should you think
about believing in your business do you
think about things that way is that is
that part of your calculus I mean you
you do so much more than just as an
investor and you you're interested in in
in a broad set of ways that the
ecosystems put together and I think that
all is part of the same picture I don't
I don't know if I I don't know if it's I
think it comes naturally hopefully and I
mean my partner Ted who you know his was
thinking about writing this blog post
about making venture capital human and
it's like when we were writing and it's
just the fact that you have to think
it's so dumb to write that that we
decided not to write it but because he's
relatively new to our firm he's been a
cowboy for a year and a half but he's
been working with startups for 20 years
and he said that that's one of things
that he noticed joining Cowboys like
that we are more maybe empathetic or
more human that a lot of VCs that he
knows but it just has so dumb to be like
hey come to us we're human that we
didn't we didn't do it if you're sure
the others are but they're a is
masquerading his people yeah interesting
a company
I mean I think I'm a person who a lot of
people may look at my resume or what I'm
doing now and think like wow she really
has it together like I have not had it
together for much of my life I have
screwed up projects I have failed at
things I have been the person on the
business school project who's a
procrastinator and like doesn't show up
with her homework done when everyone
else is ready I'm the person I have been
the person who's like slid into class
like slightly hungover being like hey
Jeff did you have notes I did not read
this case and this is all public by the
way I understood I believe people can
change I believe people evolve I believe
people learn and you like you have to
give people second chances and you have
to like believe that they're going to
get better over time like I just think
in general to be a venture investor you
have to be an optimist but like also
because like you know I was a Series A
Series B investor when I was at Kleiner
and I moved to seed and so kind of by
definition deciding to go earlier means
you want to live with people and
situations that are more raw and that
less is baked less is figured out and
that you're not trying to poke holes and
what could go wrong but you're trying to
work with the people and figure out what
what do we need to go right and that's
like just what we what we do right in
working with you know folks prior to
product market fit or you know half the
time at cowboy we the people haven't
built a product yet and half the time
they have so kind of by definition it's
what we choose to do but it's also just
I feel like I'm a product of people who
believed in me like you know John doar
and the people at Kleiner changed my
life when they hired me I was the first
woman I was the youngest I did not I was
never a working engineer I wasn't
working at a venture back startup I was
a completely non traditional hire and I
wouldn't be sitting here if people
hadn't made a bet on me as a
non-traditional hire it's interesting
when I think about John the first word
that pops in my head and it might you
know I'm Way better than me so it might
be different is thoughtful I was
thinking of like what what are the
characteristics of the great investors I
know and thoughtful and empathetic like
those like and you don't often hear
those you think about people who
like who get your product who are
familiar with labor sales are invested
in similar companies and like your your
domain but but if you think about it
the people who I think if we look at the
industry who are the best at it have
those qualities and not just the cold
hard qualities that that make for like
you know investing magic you know I I
don't know if I totally agree like I
think John and I used to do this
presentation called like there are
mercenaries and missionaries and that
one doesn't always win like you can win
if you're a mercenary and you can win as
a missionary you just have to choose
what you want to be and I think that
there are plenty of people in tech who
are pretty mercenary like they're pretty
cold they're very driven they just care
about results and they push and they
push and they're super aggressive and
you can win doing I mean I think I'm
guessing in your head you're thinking
about brands of companies in your mind
that seem like missionary companies or
mercenary companies right and there are
successful companies that are more
mercenary than missionary so I don't
think it's completely there are people
who we know were not worm and you know
don't ask you you know how you know how
your spouse is doing or your sick mom or
you know or and but and those people can
be successful it's just you have to
choose who you want to be yeah maybe
there's a connection between them which
is you should you know we always tell
this to founders is usually look for
investor who's going to be most helpful
to you and sometimes having your butt
kicked is what you need and sometimes
having someone you know understand and
understand what you're going through and
hope you still believe in your future is
what you need and I guess it depends
really is the answer
yeah and you're gonna both I think like
you can that's what you should look for
yeah I think we you know we all we have
a saying at cowboy we're always happy
never satisfied and so it's a you know
we're very grateful and we were like
positive and optimistic but you can
always do better so fundraising is
premature for some of these folks but
even if it's premature if you're a
startup you're moving fast and it'll
happen it'll it'll become relevant soon
for folks who are just in the middle as
I was saying battling for customers and
to figure out what their as we say at YC
you know talking to customers in writing
code and talking to customers and
running code and trying to trying to
find something that works and solve real
problems how should they start to think
about fundraising how do you how do you
think about that like what's what are
your first steps as you as you approach
that stage so I think something that we
have talked about here at YC and it's
funny because it's a relatively new
thing to talk about I think it's always
been there but now we have an
articulation of it which is storytelling
you know some people are naturally
natural storytellers and some are not
I think regardless of whether you are a
natural storyteller or not it's really
helpful to become one for fundraising
there are you know people want to be
emotionally engaged in your story and
the journey of your company and like and
and the arc and to feel like your
company is on an upward arc and so how
you lay out kind of how you came up with
the idea you know what work you did to
figure out whether there was a they're
there to validate or de-risk some of the
initial potential issues with your
company like I know how you've hustled
like in a way it's like a lag story like
you're engaging someone on the beginning
steps of a rags to riches story and like
showing people what you've figured out
and like what challenges you faced but
like and where you see it going is part
of how because that's a story telling is
selling you need to woo people who can
get paid much more working at Google or
Facebook right it's how you recruit
talent it's how you convince customers
to take a bet on you when you don't have
a lot of other customers right it's how
you convince people to pay like movement
to the paid like to the paid version
from the free version you know it's how
you raise money and so it's a skill that
that you can use in pretty much
everything that you do and it just takes
practice
like I think there
of people like I used to be super
nervous speaking on stage and for the
first couple years I worked in venture
when I got invited to anything to speak
I said no so Stu scared you just have to
do it a lot and so practicing your pitch
getting feedback from friendlies like we
call them like puff off Broadway's you
know like you probably don't want to
give your pitch for the first time to
that partner that you know what Sequoyah
you want to practice it you know and you
want them to register on your mind yeah
on your coat with your co-founders with
other people who raise money and
practice taking questions from them way
before you have to start fundraising
like you don't want to you know if you
have to start fundraising in December
you don't want to start your pitch in
December right you want to start your
pitch over the summer and practice it
and get lots of feedback and I mean YC
is great at providing that kind of
feedback as well yeah I don't think you
can stress enough that aspect of
practicing your pitch in a in a way that
you take feedback and learn and iterate
it's it's almost like like writing code
and talking to customers like they're
your customers anyone who will listen to
your pitch and writing code is going
back and modifying that pitch because it
probably won't work the first time you
do it they might not but you might even
ask them did you even get it at the end
and they'll say I have no idea what
you're talking about
so that aspect of practicing in and
perfecting the pitch is critical right I
think so how else to think about
fundraising I mean Jeff mentioned it
before that you know when you have a
milestone that's right in front of you
like I want to raise my seed I want to
raise my a you're very focused on that
but like Jeff mentioned the people who
have especially if you're gonna go for
institutionally back dollars whether
it's a seed fund or a larger venture
firm like when we take money from
professional investors we are have to
basically guarantor kind of to be a top
quartile fund we have to deliver a
certain kind of return top quartile
returns for more recent ventures like
vintages or let's say for a 4x return
right so if someone has a hundred
million dollar fund they have to figure
out how to generate four hundred million
dollars to be kids like to be able to
raise money in the future
and so that 400 million dollars is going
to be a combination let's say of 30
different companies two to four of which
are gonna wind up being great and the
rest of which are going to wind up not
being so great and so to kind of balance
out the averages the two to four that
have to be great have to be really great
like they have to worth a billion
dollars or more especially when you move
to a like for a seed fund if we are able
to get the right owner like you know our
first one was forty million dollars so
if we owned 10% at exit of a four
hundred million our company we could
return our fund but those kinds of like
that kind of aperture for an exit really
stops at seed like once you raise a the
people need the exits to be much bigger
because those people all have five
hundred million dollar eight hundred
million dollar funds so they need to own
10% of an eight billion dollar company
to be able to return the fund and so and
the data shows historically that most
funds don't wind up having 50 percent of
the company's all the four hundred
million dollar exits there they have two
to three B multi-billion and a bunch of
zeros or near zeros and so they're
looking at you thinking is this one of
the bullets I'm gonna fire this year to
be one of those companies that's going
to be my outsized winner they're not
thinking can I get this to two hundred
million or 300 building and they're
thinking
can this founder turn this into a
multi-billion dollar company and so the
short-term execution and story has to be
right but sorry for institutional folks
that's what's going on in their minds
yeah it seems like a lot of founders
going to the process not understanding
like if all those numbers that that a
lien was just talking about sort of
you're sort of thinking whatever
whatever it's actually vital that you
understand venture capitalists math so
that you understand what the motivations
of the person sitting across the table
from you are why they're asking how big
is your business going to be and why
they care and why although you might be
thrilled to have a 30 or 40 million
dollar exit might sound pretty good
right you own 50% of a 30 million that's
fantastic for a venture capitalist
that's like a failure and it's important
it's more to do their math because
if you want them to give you money you
better understand their math and I think
I mean it's not the answer for everyone
right like a lot of people can be
successful and get to a 40 million
dollar exit with a party round of angels
and that has happened now I think the
downside and I guess I'm a little biased
is a lot of times just having angels and
not having anyone who's a professional
investor like they may not give you the
guidance that you need on how to scale
your company on what's going on in the
market on you know what could be going
wrong or right because they're you know
they're not professionals they are high
net-worth individuals who are gonna
write your check and say keep me posted
and move on so I think you know
sometimes you have to do what you have
to do but that's always you have to do
it yeah exactly yes exactly you know
ideally you have choices right and and a
lot of what I think as you think about
sequencing your fundraising and building
your team is like basically like trying
to continually put yourself in a
position where you have good choices
right and certainly if that's the only
round you ever raise which by the way is
philosophically how you should think
about it but if you do want to continue
to be a fast growth company and raise a
Series A and seriously having
institutional's who can help you find
the partners for the next round it's
pretty important one of the things that
that also occurs to me that people don't
often talk about when it comes to
fundraising is a lot of founders forget
that that that you have to do all these
things yourself like when you started
cowboy you had to raise money you had to
go to the professional investors and
tell your story what like how is that
you know it's humbling fundraising is
humbling so it's humbling because
especially when I started cowboy I was
just me and so basically you know any
meeting that I had it was clearly a
verdict on whether they believed in me
or not now it's good that I went through
that because it and any everybody who
fund raises is gonna get some nose like
eventually someone's gonna say no to you
even if you're like the hottest company
ever or like some people are gonna pass
and but that gives me a little extra
motivation to make them really sorry
like I want them to really regret not
investing in cowboy ventures so it's
good yeah yeah I think that not enough
investors go through that experience I
think part of the problem is is that at
some point if you've been there for a
while it's the you get these funds that
just investing again again you don't
have to suffer the way a startup owner
has to suffer and I say suffer because
it's very unusual when you raise money
not to get nose right like you should
get used to it like and also just like
all the things you said when I was
raising the fun for the first time I got
a lot of smiles and a lot of like this
is great this is great I'm totally gonna
follow up send me a link to the data
room and then I would know they were not
checking the data room and when I would
check in with them they're like this is
great investment partners gonna love
this and then they would come back and
say they would either ghost me or they
would come back and say I'm so sorry I
super thought we were gonna get this
through but we didn't and I just wish
those people had not wasted my time and
so it does give us a lot of empathy and
me a lot of empathy for like following
up you know if you send me your business
plan or we have a conversation I try
really hard to get back to you and tell
you if it's not a fit for us now why and
not just smile and kind of like gfu so
that a lot of people knows are hard
right they're hard to get a lot of VCs I
think are afraid of telling you why
they're really passing because they're
you know if you do well they want to be
able to call you later
and pretend that like they were just
really busy when I passed or you know
and they're your best friend you know
yeah like how I just said about like
making you really saw if I'm not
investing they don't want to be that
person so they don't tell you why
they're really passing but doesn't
really help you so and I also think
again in fundraising getting back to
what we talked about lead qualification
so when I did my first fund raise I was
I had gotten some advice from some other
folks who were really helpful like Steve
Anderson and Mike maples and and people
who had Michael Deering who had raised
funds as a solo general partner before
me and they said the original super
angels right exactly they they said like
looking
no certain types of investors are gonna
smile and it's their job to learn about
what you're doing and so they'll meet
with you over and over again they're not
going to they're not going to come into
your first fund they're too conservative
so be careful and so I decided to create
a process or I tried to create a process
where iPhone screen everybody before I
met with them and if they hadn't
reinvested in a seed fund before and if
they didn't know who first round was or
Harrison metal and didn't have a feeling
like I had missed that or I have now
kind of I've got a budget to make sure I
don't miss the next wave of seed funds
then I just I said it'd be great to keep
in touch but let's not meet let's not
meet and so that it kind of made the
sales process a little bit more
efficient trying to really qualify leads
before spending time with them so I've
never asked you this but did you find
that that being a female and trying to
raise from LPS for a venture fund
colored the process in some way did you
feel look did you feel yes that you were
treated differently yes and sometimes it
worked out and sometimes it didn't so
I'm sure it's just we know there are
lots of studies to show that women and
men have more confidence in men right
like a woman can say the exact same
thing as a man and it will not come
across and give the same impression as
Amanda's right and so I could give a
great pitch and people would some people
probably came way as thinking like I
just don't know if she's enough of a
killer um I don't know like she has kids
what if she wakes up one day and decide
she wants to spend time with them like
you know who knows what they say but
probably all those things and you know
it would be really great if people said
that about men - I don't think we're
gonna hold our breath but you know I
think it just you know we are we're all
unfortunately biased and I mean is this
an asymmetry that's built into the
genders because we are different or is
it something that we can I'm hoping we
can work on it like there's a study I
think it's like a pen MIT study where
there was a PowerPoint deck and a
voiceover talk track
and they showed it to I think hundreds
or thousands of business school students
and they gave the Business School
students like you know you have a
hundred dollars or a thousand dollars to
invest in this company how much do you
give it and they had in the different
classes they a be tested they showed the
slides on the screen and they had a
woman speaking of it like doing the
voice-over or a man the man raised 2x
the woman same script so we have to I
mean we have to believe that this is
changeable we have to address it at
every stage of a person's life whether
you're an elementary school or junior
high or adulthood to try and catch
ourselves on our biases and yeah thing
that gives me that's it back the thing
that gave me pause there as you said
it's - for women yeah and women and
men's the female and male students both
gave the man more money so we got to
work on it but yeah so I'm sure there
were people who just you know and and
meanwhile at the same time they're a
bunch of really bro II guys with not as
good track records and probably more
like polarizing reference checks who
raised money really fast because people
were like he's such a good guy I love
that guy he goes out all the time like
everyone's gonna want to hang out with
him and give him deal flow because he's
such a great guy and like some of those
guys don't work in our business anymore
cuz it turns out that they're not really
ethical guys and they don't treat people
professionally but they raised a lot of
money but I think the great thing about
our environment right now is we talk
about it you know to five or ten years
ago we did not we just pretended this
stuff was not happening and you were
kind of unique when you started there
were so few women in the industry when
you started it and I was kind of taught
like as much as I love my former
colleagues like it was very clear I
should never talk about being a woman
and I mean like that was just at the
time was like you know keep your head
down don't don't cause problems cuz then
no one will want to hang out with you
yeah
and we shouldn't do that to people and
yeah I know you've been active in
thinking about about inclusion not just
not not just loss genderless but
diversity as well you start all raised
or maybe you can give a quick
for that as long as we're here sure so
all raised is a non-profit to try and
accelerate success for women in the tech
ecosystem so founders employees venture
investors but we hope it will create a
rising tide for all kinds of people who
are different not just women and we're
just starting out to focus on women so
all raised org is the website we started
lots of things we're like a little
startup we're a nonprofit startup that's
all volunteer driven right now if you
have heard of something called founders
for change and the new one heard of
founders for change raise your hand if
you've heard a founder changer so if you
are a founder you can go to founders for
change org and you can sign up to be a
founder for change which basically says
you're going to publicly make a
commitment to inclusion and diversity on
your team on you know when you have
choices on your team on your board and
on your cap table and you know it's not
binding you don't design assign anything
but you're just standing up and saying I
care about this and standing up and
saying I care about this is gonna say
sling to the people who are potentially
going to recruit and to the culture that
you're going to build which I think will
make your company stronger we do office
hours for female founders and we have a
matching service to try and help women
and people of color who want to get into
the venture business to kind of help get
them trained and then also match them
with firms who are looking to add more
diversity to their teams so we have like
a lot of cool products yeah the cool
thing about entrepreneurship is you
create seeds and so like entire
communities can change because someone
someone starts a company and shows that
it's possible we're talking about belief
yeah that how important belief is and
you you can inject we hope and believe
belief into a community anywhere right
anywhere in the well it's a cool thing
about startup school is a thousands of
companies from around the world that can
they can change the world that is
amazing so before we go to Q&A
You've I'll put you on the spot a little
bit hopefully you can remember how you
did this but youto like you give a
really great description of what the
components of a pitch should be and I
want to yeah I'm on it
like the and you're really good at that
and and that's a really concrete thing
that we talked about telling stories but
it's not just any story it's a story
that has components that matter because
because as we talked about venture math
the
there's there's there's a math component
there's a results component so maybe
maybe you can help these folks if I talk
if I don't do a good job of this
hopefully if there is a talk there's a
logic yeah so I do think that there are
like us on some fundament like
fundamental elements that should be in
generally all pitches so I I do like it
when people start out with the team
slide and they talk about who they are
and why they started the company and
ideally why you have a certain
background or certain things that you've
done that make you the right founders or
the right people to be solving this
problem then you talk about the problem
you know why is it a problem and then
you talk about how big it is and
investors are usually looking for
problems that are billions of dollars so
if the a and then you know and not just
the overall market the addressable
market so you know if you know if a
market in real estate is you know five
billion dollars but you can only get
Timbers on the market your addressable
market is only two to five hundred
million and that's often too small for
venture investors so they really want
your addressable market to be at least
let's say five or ten billion because
they want to know that if you are really
successful and you get tempers on the
market that you could be making at least
hundreds of millions of dollars so then
you talk about your product or your
solution right which is like this is you
know this is what we've built to solve
the problem here's how it works
and ideally you talk a little bit about
what's special about it what's your
unique insight what's the technology you
develop that's again that makes it so
different and oftentimes it has to be
like a 10x difference like a 1 to 2x
difference is not enough it's hard to
get people to try new things and so
there has to be a real significant
benefit to get someone to switch from
what they're doing to try something new
and you might talk about the competitive
landscape and there people are looking
for your your honesty and your
transparency you know some founders tend
to hand-wave competition like oh they
all suck and they're all stupid like
that's you know that doesn't show that
you're gonna be nested like honest about
what's going on and that there are other
people who are already out there doing
what you're doing or have like that
other people currently use or that other
people have certain features that you
don't have yet because investors and
board members don't want to have to
haircut what you're saying when you're
talking about how the business is going
they want to know that you guys that you
can be honest and transparent with each
other about the reality of what's
happening then you might have a
financial plan and talk about and
oftentimes like a three-year plan is a
good thing it doesn't have to be by
month but kind of like maybe what you're
going to get done by month in the next
12 months and then what the annual
revenue in revenues or what the PNL
looks like and what investors are
looking for is both the top-line in
terms of the revenue numbers and the
revenue growth the margins of the
business and that costs that go into the
business and both the gross margin and
also like how much you're planning on
spending on marketing how much of the
money is going to go to technology
development and people versus buying ads
and things like that and then how much
cash you're planning on consuming over
the next three years that's pretty much
it that helped yeah that's awesome I was
going to say in the financial plan some
of that depends on how far along you are
how involved you are you might have a
CAC and you might not but you ought to
have some idea how you're gonna make
money like you ought to be able to
describe why it's a business as opposed
to some service that people might want
but might not pay for when they end up
deny things good to have like a summary
slide like you know if you've ever taken
public speaking or a presentation class
they'll tell you like I'm gonna tell you
what I'm gonna tell you and then I'm
gonna tell you and then I'm gonna tell
you what I told you
so Kunsan has this slide deck can be
that too or you start out with a summary
slide like you know here's here the
highlights of what we do and then you go
into the whole thing and then you say
and again here are the highlights so um
before we take Q&A there's I'm sure
you're so sick of talking about unicorns
and that like to have some sides having
them so so so Aileen is famous because
or infamous I don't know for inventing
the term hated unicorn and I just had
like I had a question why unicorn we're
not like dragon or like why is it an
animal why isn't it like a diamond Dora
where did that come from
Mike maples from flood floodgate of any
of you he's such a good he's like King
storyteller and he used to call big like
you know big winner company is thunder
dragons which is super perfect so dragon
was taken
a thunder dragon was taken I wrote I
wrote the analysis so basically I had
this new fund and I was you know that
the lore had been it's you know out of
30 companies who wanted having two
winners and a bunch of not-so-great
companies and so I had asked LPS for the
data so I was just trying to figure out
like is that really true
and if I could basically a great the
data of other people's funds to
understand what like get what had what
was the composition of their winders you
know where did the founders come from
how did they know each other
what birth order were they like all
these questions of you know if you have
a clean you know of a clean dance card
and there's a kajillion seed stage
companies out there are there any things
that the most successful companies in
the past decade have had in common that
I should know to be looking for and I
could not I had such a hard time
collecting the data so I wind up to
starting a spreadsheet and making a list
of companies that had been born within
the past ten years that were worth over
a billion dollars and I just started
like making a list of where they went to
college how many co-founders there were
when they were born how like you know so
therefore how old were they when they
founded the company had they worked in
tech before like it just had a thousand
columns and how much you know - they
sent that I could learn how much they
raised at the a at the B what was the
time period between the rounds like all
the things to see what they had in
common and so I kind of rode up my and I
there were a bunch of things that I
think were a little bit contrarian at
the time like mo the most successful
founders of the prior decade were in
their 30s when they started and you know
the the conventional wisdom was like you
have to drop out of college and start
when you're 20 and I had been meeting
with founders who were kind of
apologetic when we met they're like I'm
so sorry I'm 32 I know I'm really old
and I was like no don't don't apologize
like you have work experience that's
actually important which is interesting
because if you look at the earlier stage
like the first stages adventure everyone
will everyone starting enterprise
companies and they were all like to
start an enterprise companies you need
to know something about enterprises they
were all in their 30s 40s and 50s
yeah and that was one of the differences
in the annales
that consumer founders tended to be
younger than Enterprise founders when
they founded the companies because yeah
exactly what you said so so there are a
bunch of things in the analysis like
like the vast majority of companies had
co-founders and there's a reason why I
like being a solo founder is hard really
um being a co founders really had
exactly and also they were people who
had had contacts like they had lived
together or work together a gun to
college so it was like very rare that
you that you meet a co-founder on a
blind date and that that I mean this
holes dataset of 39 companies early
they're all outliers so it's not like
it's there's no statistical significance
so these are all just examples or
stories of kind of the making of but I
thought that there was some useful
things so I wrote this analysis up of
like what are the things I've learned
from this analysis and then I was yeah I
had this phrase of like you know public
or private companies less than ten years
old that have become worth over a
billion dollars that I had written over
and over again
in the piece and it was just so hard
hard to read so I was like I got to come
up with a shorter word is it home run is
it mega hit is like what and they it
just all sad so lame let's go catch oh
yeah that's it and then I I put in
unicorn and it made it so much easier
just popped into your hook yeah well I
was thinking like you know the thing is
that it is almost like alchemy like you
could do all the right things and have
the right background and try super hard
for ten years and this could and it
might not happen for you because it just
it really is quite rare out of thousands
of thousands of companies being born
every year in getting funding only
thirty nine at the time and still even
now if the number is 100 or 120 whatever
then or is it still like out of all the
companies that are born every year a
very very small fraction so the idea was
kind of like it is like magic and also I
wanted it to feel special and magical
not kind of laboratory clinical somehow
it just and it immediately caught on one
of those means dead took off yeah so
thank you thank you
questions for operations product of
marketing so what's the distribution of
funds proper distribution of funds
during a from a seed round what kind of
a company a I powered it's mostly
probably going to be team and technology
right you're probably not going to have
you're probably not gonna want to spend
a lot of money on customer acquisition
right you're going to want to build
something where the tech is so unique
and so attractive that you don't have to
spend money to acquire customer so I
would think that it's largely gonna be
team probably yeah yeah yeah like the
cost and distribution of funds is hard
because soft from feelings answer it
depends so much on what kind of company
most most software companies spend
almost all their funds on people
hardware companies a little bit
different yeah back there so how do you
look at non-traditional founders and how
do they go about showing you that they
they too can be founders of unicorns I
guess III add at that last part but I
think that's what he meant yeah I mean I
think like what we were talking before
about the story and how you explain like
you know how you came across the problem
that you're trying to solve what your
personal passion is for it and what
you've figured out like a lot at seed
there's not a lot of data right a lot
you haven't maybe shipped your product
you don't have customers there's no
cohorts but what you can talk about is
your hustle right your insight when
you've hit roadblocks what you figure it
what was your workaround and what you
figured out that's really what a lot of
seed stage investors are looking at is
you know do you have that grit and like
the right skill set to figure out and so
seed in the space I mean I think it's a
better time than ever to be a
non-traditional founder I friend Ally
Rosenthal who's raising a fund right now
and her focus is going to be non-obvious
founders you know it's it's like this
was not a thing a decade ago but now I
think both we realized that you know
investors have probably just been
hunting in too much of the same pool
over and over again companies don't need
to be based in the barrier anymore
Richard Kirby did a great analysis
showing that like the diversity aventure
is a huge problem not just in terms of
gender and race but the majority of
people who work in venture went to
Stanford and Harvard there's just no way
that that's the right answer right you
know it just missed opportunity yes tons
and so I think it's a great time to be a
non-traditional founder so how did if
you meet lots of VCS how do you choose
them less based on just gut intuition
and more on some sort of rational basis
so I would recommend on both we do
reference checks on both sides like when
we're thinking about investing in a
company we try and do reference checks
not so much like criminal background
checks but more understanding you where
you work before what your strengths are
how you need to be complimented what
you've experienced and the same thing
founders should feel comfortable if you
you know when you have choices it's it's
hard it's very hard to get divorced from
your investors and so you should
reference check investors agree just
investment in company in they did a lot
of so the question is has to do with
raising on a convertible with a cab
if you raise 250 thousand and can you
vary that cap across different investors
I mean I think the cap question has a
lot to do with the market right and what
choices you have so you know I wouldn't
take the first offer that you have and
it'll assess it with a dilution right
I'm thinking about what dilution you're
willing to live with knowing that this
is probably going to but not going to be
the only dilution you're gonna see right
and so you know you a good rule of thumb
is generally you have to imagine that in
every round like your seed round or a
round and then it's decreasing at B and
C you're probably gonna sell between
twenty and thirty percent of your
company over time so you think about
like how much money realistically you
may have to raise over how many rounds
looking at companies in your space how
many rounds like most people think that
they should only have to raise through B
and then they wind up raising through F
I think it just happens that waiver is a
reason and so you think about you know
you want it you want to get the capital
and not have to spend too much time
fundraising but also you don't want to
experience too much dilution my personal
opinion is the different caps is a
really bad idea if there's a gap if
there's a time gap between when you
raise that's all right but otherwise all
you're likely to do is to have a bunch
of pissed-off investors which as Ian
says you're gonna live with for a long
time and that's never a healthy
relationship you are really getting
married to your to your investors that
you you're creating a long-term
relationship
so I'll it seldom starts on a positive
foot to find out that the person you
talk to 15 minutes before got a better
deal than you did yeah
you thanks a lot for that today I mean
you mentioned that used to call the VCS
and the firm's when you were early on
but today I think it's all about getting
the reference right reference times you
know we see so sorry in donors who came
out of not work there not from us oh
they're from outside this area they
don't have height preference so what is
your recommendation for temp to reach
out to the PCs how do you reach out to
VCS what's the recommendation you know
or get a warm intro if you're not from
from the from the area and you don't or
you're not from Stanford or Harvard
right I think it's both you know I think
a lot of especially seed firms take cold
intros all the time
we take cold end pounds all the time and
a lot of it depends on what you say in
the email about what the market is that
you're going after what you figured out
so far we meet with people all the time
that just emailed us a traditional VC
was you yet you just received a whole
bunch of business but no one knew the
VCS they were sitting off on Sand Hill
Road no one knew them exactly and they
got business plans so yeah it still
exists so but I do think it's helpful
because I think it's a you know figuring
out how to get a warm intro in some ways
I think is a test of your hustle and
your ability to network and build
relationships when you especially are
from the outside so I think that's one
of the reasons why people use it as a
filter it's like you know if you're not
good at figuring out how to like start
from you know a cold like a stop and
then like to get some momentum then you
know maybe you're not gonna be a great
entrepreneur so I would try both yeah I
think one one thing to think about is
that like it's a pretty small world here
everyone knows everyone Saul I got to do
it like to find someone who's connected
to alien like like elbow three people
and you'll find somebody so it's it's
not as hard as you might think maybe
someone from
[Music]
and happy thoughts about that and why
that is so the question is on a study
that found that women the companies
founded by women are evaluated 84% less
than I guess male founders I'm not sure
if they normalized over industries yeah
I haven't read that study I I mean I
think a lot of the studies the if you
look at the Unicorn list right now right
there's only like two female founders in
the whole list right so if you're doing
an average across venture yes of course
like those companies are the vast
majority of the kind of paper wealth
that's been driven in the past decade in
the industry and if there's no female
co-founders or you know that that own
the equity of or and these are the most
valuable companies in our industry then
yeah it's that would make sense and I
think even if you just if you looked at
it like kind of apples to apples across
seed my guess is the analysis will find
that and parsley for some of the reasons
that we talked about that women founded
companies tend to be underestimated by
investors partially due to bias but
women also can I think we can you know
we can work on it on the Investor side
to try and take away some of the bias
and then we can also work out on the
founder side kind of helping and
coaching women on how to tell stories
and how to pitch like I'm fortunate to
have worked with some women who have
raised a lot of money at very healthy
valuations and in very competitive
situations where they've been multiple
bidders and the price like you know the
multiples relative to revenue or run
rate or like you know what they figure
it out have been you know quite high a
lot of times it comes to the story like
what both what the founders have figured
out and how they tell the story so I'm
sorry we were going to take one more
question because time is flown in the
back
[Music]
so the question is when you're analyzing
the factors that went in the various
characteristics of unicorns were there
any factors that surprised you was that
surprised that we're surprising that
actually mattered oh that did Matt well
which factors did not matter that was it
that were surprised oh that's a good
question I don't know if I have a good
quick answer for you on that one just
because I focus so much I'm like where
they were signal I don't even know if I
remember the things that it didn't have
signal okay we'll take one more question
then right there you only get one you
have to pick one pick the best one so
they're looking for especially with the
curry optional distribution and I'm
coming at it from I have no idea how to
concisely say that a question it's
something about aligning objectives
where where where is I don't know I
don't know if I get it
yeah can you can you try to make your
put your question in like a very concise
short one sentence understandable format
so the test investor who's seeking a
higher return how do you align your
objectives with enabling a lot of
companies that are looking for the
lowest cost to market in terms of so how
do you balance the high return that
investors are looking for with companies
that need to very to compete in a very
price-sensitive market is that right I
think they're aligned I mean we have you
know your investors have the same goals
right which is we want to help you get
to market so we can quickly get feedback
on whether there's a dare there on the
product right and so helping you figure
out like what are the things that you
look what's your Minimum Viable Product
one of the things that are nice to have
versus need to have like for example
oftentimes when we hear a steed pitch
someone will be like well I need all
this money cuz I have to build both
Android and iPhone and we'll say like
well we don't have any market validation
yet why would we build both let's just
spend money on one of them see if people
like it and then we'll build the other
one right so like those are examples I
think what they're very aligned in that
we work together to figure out how do we
get our product out there and get
feedback and kind of conserve our cash
that we don't blow it all before we have
actually learned anything it all comes
to the same thing okay sorry to cut it
off guys thanks very much thank you so
much thanks for coming
[Applause]
you